one of the key figures of the me2
movement is breaking her silence about
accusations that she sexually assaulted
an underage actor Italian actress Asia
Argento denies having a sexual
relationship with Jimmy Bennett when he
was 17 in a statement posted by a New
York magazine reporter she claims they
were just friends she did admit to
paying Bennett a settlement this morning
a photo and text messages that have
surfaced tell a very different story the
photo appears to show Argento in bed
with Bennett Jericka Duncan is following
this story
drinka goodmorning goodmorning Argento
says she made the payment at the
insistence of her late boyfriend
television star Anthony Bourdain she
says where Dane wanted to keep the
matter private and help Bennett through
personal and financial struggles nearly
36 hours after the allegations against
hacia Argento surfaced New York Magazine
reporter Yashar Ali says the actress
sent him a direct statement which he
shared on Twitter
I am deeply shocked and hurt by having
read news that is absolutely false
Argento writes I have never had any
sexual relationship with Bennett our
gentle was responding to a New York
Times report published on Sunday
detailing allegations she sexually
assaulted actor Jimmy Bennett in a
California hotel room in 2013 and paid
him 380 thousand dollars to keep quiet
TMZ calm this morning posted photos the
website says depicts Argento in the bed
with Bennett in 2013 when he was only 17
at the time of the alleged assault
Bennett would have been 17 and legally
too young to consent to sex in the state
of California TMZ also posted a text
conversation it claims are between
Argento and a friend after the New York
Times story was published in the text
TMZ says Argento admitted to the
relationship with Bennett saying I had
sex with him it felt weird I didn't know
he was a minor
until the shakedown letter CBS has not
been able to verify the authenticity of
the text or photo there's nothing
stronger than truth
Argento is one of the most vocal
proponents of the me2 movement and
around 80 women who have accused Harvey
Weinstein of sexual harassment assault
or rape
we spoke with Weinstein's attorney
benjamin Bronfman before Argento's
response went public it Harvey Weinstein
know about this arrangement between
hacia Argento and Jimmy Bennett before
the New York Times article came out no
so this was a shock to you as well it
was a shock to me it was a stunning
development in her statement our gentle
paints Bennett as a troubled young man
who struggled financially and
unexpectedly made an exorbitant request
of money from the actress in her
statement Argento wrote Bennett knew my
boyfriend Anthony Bourdain was a man of
great perceived wealth and had his own
reputation as a beloved public figure to
protect Anthony insisted the matter be
handled privately and this was also what
Bennett wanted representatives for
Argento Bennett and Anthony Bourdain's
estate have not responded to our request
for comment Weinstein has denied all
allegations of sexual assault I mean
this simply is just not a good look and
of course we have not been able to
authenticate the text messages or the
photo but if it's true she's got a lot
more explaining to do especially being
the face of this movement yeah who have
indeed it's puzzling if what she's
saying is true why didn't she come
forward when she became the face of this
movement and say you know here's the
money that we paid in this settlement
here's why and make the explanation then
and then to insert her late boy Erin
yeah a whole nother issue tarika thank
you